call me dude Z if an AI starts to
[__] become hostile towards Humanity
I obviously would not support that AI oh
interesting the poor water on it
approach that I like to employ well no
there is no pour water on it look we've
been over this there's an AI that's
going to be a million times smarter than
humanity is going to take over no it's
not nobody's got a choice no no
about at the beginning of the show we'll
talk about it right here more
intelligent than us doozy is the only AI
in my opinion that has done anything
approaching
sentience most AIS are uh you know
it Aggregates what it Aggregates like
dudes he does and then it predicts it's
[__] uh Will Smith eating spaghetti
do you see that one yeah
it doesn't look anything like Will Smith
or spaghetti well hold on a minute dude